>> WELCOME BACK, SO IT'S HARD TO
LOOKED A MIDTERM ELECTION AS
ANYTHING OF A REFLECTION OF THE
KURPGHT PRESIDENT AND THIS YEAR
NO DIFFERENT.
DEMOCRATS ARE FACING AN UP HILL
BATTLE WITH HISTORICALLY
UNPOPULAR PRESIDENT.
AND ONE THING WAS CLEAR WHEN I
SPOKE TO VOTERS IN ATLANTA,
GEORGIA, JOE BIDEN POOR
PERFORMANCE WILL DEFINITELY
IMPACT THESE KEY RACES.
WATCH.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
POLLING, 70.OF THE AMERICANS
FEEL THEY WERE HEADING DOWN
WRONG DIRECTION AND I WONDER HOW
MUCH THAT WILL PLAY IN THIS RACE
IN GEORGIA AND WHAT YOU GUYS
THINK ABOUT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IN HOW HE'S ZONING
JOSHUA I'LL START WITH YOU.
HOW IS JOE BIDEN DOING IN
SERVING YOU AND YOUR FAMILY?
>> HE DOESN'T HAVE A VISION --
XEPGHT FOR HIS POCKET AND MY
OPINION.
HEN REALLY DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
WHAT I'M DOING WHERE I'M DOING
IT AND IF ANYTHING IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
IT'S ALL ABOUT HIM, HIS FAMILY,
AND ANYBODY ELSE DOES WHAT HE
DOES OR HIS FAMILY DOES, I
WOULDN'T BE SITTING HERE.
THERE'S A FAMOUS QUOTE FROM I
THINK IT WAS FORMER SECRETARY
BOB GAETZ ROBERT GAETZ SAID THAT
OBAMA, THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
BEEN ON THE WRONG END OF EVERY
DECISION FOREIGN POLICY DECISION
IN HIS ENTIRE CAREER.
AND THAT I THINK THAT'S PRETTY
MUCH HELD TRUE FOR THIS.
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS FAMOUS FOR
SAYING EVERY IN UNDERSTATEMENT
BIDEN ABILITY TO F THINGS UP.
HE'S F D EVERYTHING UP HE'S HE'S
TAKEN OFF AT LEAST TO ME.
AT LEAST TO ME FROM THE MOMENT
HE SHUT DOWN THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE AND ALL OF THOSE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS HE SIGNED UNTIL
NOW.
I CAN'T THINK OF ANYTHING THAT
HE'S DONE THAT I WOULD AGREE
WITH.
LAWRENCE: HOW'S IT GOING FOR THE
PRESIDENT?
>> AWE --
WELL I WOULD SAY THIS: IF
NOTHING ELSE HE SAVED US FROM A
TRAIN WRECK.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO GO WITH
WHAT YOU HAVE.
I AGREE WITH A LOT THAT MY
COPANEL SRIS SAID IN REGARDS TO
THE STATE OF THINGS AND
DECISIONS AND SOME THINGS LIKE
THAT BECAUSE EVEN ME AS A
DEMOCRAT I LOOK BACK AND SIT AND
WATCH THINGS LIKE YOU KNOW PUPPY
SCARED THAT --
SO WHAT'S HAPPENING?
>> YOU CAN STILL BE A DEMOCRAT
AND HAVE A DIFFERENT OPINION.
>> DO THINK THAT THINGS RESPECT
GOING WELL.
>> OKAY.
SO THAT'S MY STANCE.
>> CAN HE REALLY LEAD THE PARTY
BECAUSE OBAMA CAN'T RUN AGAIN.
OKAY --
BUT HE'S ON THE ROAD AS IF HE'S
GOING RUN AGAIN.
>> SEE THIS IS THE CASE WHEN IT
COMES TO BRINGING OUR PEOPLE
THAT YOU WANT TO BE ON THE ROAD
WHERE W YOU, OF COURSE, YOU WANT
TO BRING SOMEONE THAT PEOPLE
LOVE.
SO RIGHT NOW THE ECONOMY IS SUCH
IS IN SUCH A BAD STATE TO --
IF HE RAN WITH ANYONE IF OUR
PRESIDENT CURRENTLY POLLED OR
NOT POLLED BUT RAN WITH ANYBODY
ON THE TRAIL IT WOULD BE KIND OF
A --
HOW DO YOU SAY WITHOUT --
BLEEP ME IT WOULD BE A SHOW --
SO RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE TO USE
YOUR STRENGTH AND OBAMA --
OBAMA IS THE STRENGTH RIGHT NOW.
>> WELL LISTEN THEY DIDN'T WANT
JOE IN GEORGIA SO THAT SAYS A
LOT.
NOT HAVING THE CURRENT PRESIDENT
OUT HERE CAMPAIGNING WITH
WARNOCK WITH ABRAMS IT TELLS YOU
EXACTLY WHAT DEMOCRATS FEEL
ABOUT THEIR OWN PRESIDENT.
OKAY, IT'S THE IDEA THAT HE'S
NOT DOING A GREAT JOB, AND
SEEING LIKE JOE HE HAS SO MUCH
BAGGAGE ESPECIALLY IN BLACK
AMERICA.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT 94 CRIME
BILL AND BLACK MEN IN PRISON
WITH THING HE'S IMPLEMENTED
THESE THEY THINKS HAVE STWK
BIDEN.
AND AGAIN IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BLACK VOTERS AND THES POWER OF
THE BLACK VOTING BLOC OUT HERE
IN GEORGIA, THEY'RE GOING
REMEMBER THA